some breaking news today from the
highest court in the u.s justice stephen
breyer reportedly plans to retire from
the supreme court which would allow the
biden administration to put forth its
first nominees so for more on what's
next let's bring in kimberly robinson
she is bloomberg law's supreme court
reporter kim really joins us live from
arlington virginia kimberly uh breyer is
83 years old so that makes him the
oldest justice so it's not a total
surprise that he's stepping down what
can you tell us about the timeline for
his exit and his replacement
well the timeline has shifted a little
bit so prior to the last uh supreme
court uh confirmation
confirmation hearings generally took uh
several months from when the retirement
was announced to when a successor was
confirmed but of course after the death
of ruth bader ginsburg senate
republicans pushed through amy coney
barrett at a rocket speed and so that
timeline went down to about a month so
certainly we could see some pretty quick
movement on this although we don't have
to i suspect the
game plan for democrats and for the
white house is to get this nomination
done before the midterm elections and
they have plenty of time to do that and
we should note that this is the earliest
supreme court retirement announcement
since the early 90s giving biden plenty
of time but kimberly i'm curious could
republicans still potentially step in
and derail things at all and you know
could some democrats who are swing
voters even potentially derailed this
timeline
right so we've seen a lot of derailing
on some of the biden administration's
key legislative items
and some talk over the filibuster
particularly from senators mansion and
cinema
here for supreme court nominees there
only needs to be 50 votes so as long as
all democrats are on board and
there will be the vice president to
break a tie and you know we have seen
those two those two senators step out
from the democratic party on other
issues but on judicial nominations
that's something we've seen them be
lockstep with the other democrats on and
i suspect something this big and this
historic that they will continue to
support biden's judicial nominees what
about republicans then i know you
mentioned that you only need 50 votes
with the vice president breaking the tie
but is there any way for republicans in
the senate to derail this or might we
even see some
republican senators perhaps cross party
lines and vote with the democrats
well crossing party lines of voting with
democrats is something that we just
don't see anymore um i do think that
with president biden suggesting that
he'll not
eliminate the court's first black woman
that might uh change the calculus a
little bit for some republicans um
though i do think it'll be pretty close
to that 50 vote threshold um and but you
know again that's something we have to
go wait and see i don't think that
there's anything procedurally
republicans can do at this point
but uh former senate
leader mitch mcconnell has already said
that if this nomination is still open
after the midterm elections and if
republicans take over the senate that
they will
block president biden's nominee so i'm
sure that the white house is working a
pretty quick speed to make sure that
doesn't happen
i'm curious too you talked about the
filibuster another potential shift
that's come up for the biden
administration is term limits for
supreme court justices whatever happened
to that can you update us on that whole
dynamic
sure so uh the president did put in
place the supreme court commission and
they came out with their findings but
the findings weren't ever intended to be
a recommendation instead they were more
like a book report the pros and cons of
term limits and since that's come out we
haven't heard anything from the white
house we don't even have a timeline on
um you know what the supreme court or
what the white house might do with those
uh recommendations and findings so so
far we're on a holding pattern on those
i will say that you know groups who
interest groups who watch the supreme
court still have expanding the court top
of mind but i wonder if having this
nominee may kind of bring the
temperature down on that issue
interesting especially since there were
a lot of groups that were um
i wouldn't say picketing but really
pushing the idea that briar should step
down last summer and they obviously
didn't get anywhere with that at the
time
give us a little bit more of a sense of
who justice stephen breyer is because
he's 83 he's been uh the justice uh the
longest-serving justice at the moment
and i feel like we don't know a whole
lot about him
well that's right and one of the reasons
that we don't know a lot about him is
that justice breyer actually spent 11
years as the court's most junior justice
and so he didn't really write a lot of
the bigger um cases that we think of
when we think of a justice who have
served on the supreme court this long
instead his legacy has really been kind
of behind the scenes creating consensus
so i think that's going to be a big part
of his legacy but another thing is that
he's a very pragmatic justice where a
lot of the other justices want to put
brightline rules you know does a certain
issue fall on one side of the line or
another justice breyer is a little more
wishy-washy and wants to weigh lots of
factors so that's kind of an element i
think that uh we'll be missing without
justice breyer on the court um but you
know and for me personally one thing
that i will miss as a supreme court
reporter who's in the courtroom a lot is
justice breyer is just known for his
crazy off-the-wall hypotheticals yeah
that really make um listening to oral
arguments interesting so that's
something personally i'm going to be
interested in and i think will also be
part of his legacy as well yeah kimberly
i'm a huge hypotheticals nerd this is
like the way that my friends and i hang
out with each other is just insane
hypothetical questions walk me through
your favorites from briar what are your
all-star hypothetical moments that stick
out to you
well we actually have a video on this
that we did last year when clamor around
his retirement came and it reminded me
of some of the funniest ones he talks
about um these giant tomatoes that grow
into people and then go around
destroying cities and to be honest i
can't even tell you what legal principle
that was trying to get at i think
marijuana laws or something right i
think that's right that sounds about
right um we've also seen in products
liabilities cases him talk about you
know ice cream stands that poison their
customers um just really anything and
everything you can talk about he has a
really unique way of kind of honing in
on the particular legal issue that's
bothering him what an interesting
thinker who would bring up deadly tomato
children or you know
ice cream stands at that are deadly so
let's continue with this hypothetical
idea um of course everyone's going to be
wondering who's on the white house this
short list and you know i think back to
episodes of the west wing where they
pull out a list that they've already
drawn up and are going through all the
names and and bring them into the white
house to interview them and and do all
the due diligence what can you tell us
about who is at the top of the list you
mentioned
president biden had promised to nominate
a black woman
that's right and i think this is one
reason why the process could move along
pretty quickly i think common thinking
is that there are two women
at the top of the white house's list
although some others who may be um
kind of vying for an underdog seat and
that's leandra kruger who currently sits
as a justice of the california supreme
court and uh federal judge contanji
brown jackson who was actually just
elevated uh from the district court in
dc to the dc circuit last year and
that's considered one of the or the
second most important uh federal court
in the nation so that's where we've
gotten a lot of our current supreme
court justices so that puts her in
pretty good company yeah and apparently
uh kentucky brown jackson was also a
former briar clerk as well just kind of
complete that picture absolutely and
carry on that legacy kimberly i i want
to go back to some uh potential
roadblocks that abide in nominee could
potentially face if if one of the women
who you just spoke about is the selected
nominee what do you anticipate being the
biggest roadblock that senate
republicans potentially voice in in that
confirmation process
well i wonder if it's something around
affirmative action and the reason i say
that is because the supreme court just
this week said that it was going to
consider overturning some of its
decades-old cases allowing affirmative
action in higher education so of course
there are other big ticket items on the
supreme court's
docket this term abortion and gun rights
but a lot of those will be decided and
so just looking forward at what's coming
before the quarter i wonder if
affirmative action and other racial
issues are going to be pretty big um on
the list that the gop members of the
senate are going to be asking about and
wondering about yeah that's definitely
top of mind are we past the point
kimberly where um a supreme court
justice's um
history when it comes to paying for
child care is going to come up i think
of zoe baird who of course was nominated
by president clinton but and then ended
up have to withdraw her nomination
because she had hired undocumented
immigrants and failed to pay their
social security taxes when they were
taking care of her children because she
was serving as a judge
yeah i think that um you know
one of the reasons that these two people
these two women are on the top of the
list or because they have been vetted
quite a bit um and so as i mentioned uh
brown jackson
was just confirmed last year she already
went through a pretty hard confirmation
battle and was able to withstand the
test and then leandra kruger just has so
many of those you know boxes that you
need to check in order to be on the
supreme court and i really tested
uh history as a justice of the
california supreme court but i think a
lot of those lurking
i'm issues going to be there with these
two really no nominees oh wait sorry my
mistake actually u.s attorney general um
was the actual position she was
nominated no but it's a great point
scarlett and kimberly i guess i want to
ask a very low level question of you
here if the court is going to continue
to be a 6-3 conservative liberal split
why does it matter what these potential
justices think about affirmative action
what's the case there good question
yeah i think
you're
right on the bottom line uh holding from
the supreme court it's not going to make
very much of a difference we already
know what stephen brier thinks about
affirmative action and i suspect that's
going to be what any democratic nominee
thinks as well they could have a
difference in you know the dissenting
opinions and these dissenting opinions
are really seen as not speaking to the
other justices on the court now but
speaking to the future and i think
that's where these could really have a
different um kind of a different impact
and also you know it could be that you
know one of these two candidates or any
other black woman that president binay
could nominate to this seat could really
add a different perspective um for the
just
this is on the supreme court you know
currently we have two justices on the
court who have experienced with
affirmative action justices sotomayor
and justice thomas and they come at it
from wildly
different views and wildly different
experiences so had an impact the way
that the opinions get written whether
they're more narrow or more sweeping um
and in particular how the dissents are
written for the future that's really
important of course to remember kimberly
thank you so much kimberly robinson
hopping on with us from bloomberg law to
give us instant insight into what the
briar's reported retirement means for
the balance of the supreme court